the lethal Santa Ana winds are returning
to Southern California firefighters
working round-the-clock trying to dampen
down smoldering land that's threatening
to reignite thousands of acres of land
have been burnt to a cinder hundreds of
homes and businesses destroyed whole
communities wrecked in the most lethal
wildfire storm since records began more
than eight thousand firefighters are now
deployed fighting three wildfires
amongst them Engine Company 279 and they
just really get going and it becomes a
full-on fire anything that smoking can
get going in Europe well we spent the
day with them as they search for
potential flare-ups here burning
fractured gas mains a problem they can't
solve
what can you do I was hoping I could see
a vowel but it looks like it's best
destroyed so it's just an open fight
with nothing we can do right now so you
get the gas people come and look at it
there's a mandatory evacuation order in
Malibu and most people have gone
searching for the next potential fire is
nerve-racking stuff this team has been
here from the very start of the
fastest-moving wildfire
they have ever seen and that's what's
igniting the houses every time there's a
gust of wind - amber caps and whatever's
burning is hurrying that a mile down the
road and igniting it ahead laughter
there we could get there and the winds
were going fast as well oh yeah it was
the scale of the damage and to some of
the most expensive properties in the
world will cost billions to sort out
what really strikes you is the
randomness of the firestorm this house
is in really good condition in fact it's
barely been touched we're in Malibu one
of the richest areas of this part of
California this is a beautiful house you
come up to the front door though you'll
see that once you get past the metal
absolutely nothing is left completely
and utterly destroyed and this house was
worth millions and millions of dollars
yeah kept on going and I kept going
across down the hill organic farmer
carried Class B tried to fight the
flames from her roof this picture was
taken two moments before she simply had
to give up
she's lost her personal possessions but
her business remains and then the wind
shifted and it was like I knew I was
right at that moment we were done we're
toast
and I remember yelling c-czar and he
came up and we both looked at each other
when we knew we had to evacuate and we
didn't even have to evacuate we just
stood there and watched everything
burned down the weather forecasts are
not good the winds are expected to blow
for a few more days the fight to control
the fires were
Tinh you but there's only so much they
can actually do Stewart Ramsay Sky News
Malibu